just this last week we were we received
Outreach from an IRS whistleblower
requesting the committee look into
concerns the individual has about
allegations of misconduct so can you
commit that there will be no retail
retaliation against that whistleblower I
can say without any hesitation there
will be no retaliation for anyone making
a an allegation or a call to a
whistleblower hotline
now in the words of Maury Povich the lie
detector test determined that was a lie
now just two and a half weeks after the
IRS commissioner claimed no
whistleblower would ever be punished the
attorney for one set his entire team had
been removed from the hunter Biden
investigation now this is the same
whistleblower by the way who allege
nearly a month ago that the probe was
being mishandled by the bite
Administration now his attorney says The
Whistleblower was informed of the
removal was at the request of the
Department of Justice joining me now
house ways and means committee chair
Jason Smith Congressman wonderful to see
you tonight what are you going to do
about this you know this is absolutely
ridiculous um I said I was going to run
the Ways and Means Committee different
and that Ways and Means has always not
been known as an oversight committee my
first week we set up the Whistleblower
hotline should be an oversight committee
absolutely absolutely and so for any IRS
employee could contact us as the
Committee of jurisdiction for
congressional oversight could let us
know of anything we need to look at and
we've gotten some whistleblowers and
that's why I asked the IRS commissioner
just less than three weeks ago if there
would be any retaliation for the the the
whistleblowers is coming forward and he
said absolutely not well yesterday I
received a letter from the Council of
one of the Whistleblower blowers
whistleblowers that said that he was
removed off of this high profile case
along with other individuals of his team
it was done by the justice department so
we sent him a letter this afternoon we
sent a letter to the IRS commissioner
asking to asking us to give us the
information there's only two things
either he's not telling the truth before
sworn testimony before Congress or two
someone higher up directed him to do
this well a few weeks ago the attorney
for the IRS whistleblower responded to a
statement from Hunter Biden's attorney
accusing The Whistleblower of committing
a crime to harm Hunter watch this it's
really unfortunate that that statement
was made I client wrestled with whether
or not to come forward he had a lot of
sleepless nights about coming forward
with this at the end of the day he
decided that he could not live with
himself if he stayed quiet and said
nothing so he's coming forward but he
knows that he's going to be attacked and
you know really attacks like this are
kind of what he was worried about
your reaction to that Congressman the
law the laws that we have are to protect
whistleblowers not for whistleblowers to
be fearful of retaliation if people are
fearful of retaliation they're never
going to come forward that's the problem
haven't Democrats uh you know during the
whole vinman thing and that that's
sacrosanct for them we thought this is
correct this is absolutely terrible
um the fact that you're seeing an
individual that uh did not want to come
public but just saw misconduct at the
IRS and felt like that it needed to get
to a higher source they should be
allowed to do that that's what oversight
is all about this is this is
um why a lot of people fear the IRS for
example the IRS is the most feared
agency they're fearful of weaponization
well they have full resources the
federal government they have unlimited
resources and if they want pretty much
unlimited staff and correct after the 80
billion dollars that they got in the 87
000 new agents are trying to power the
purse Congressman power of the purse you
guys have it that's why remains has it
that's why we put it in the the limit
save grow act with the debt limit to
repeal it we've done two pieces of
legislation we got to continue to Chip
Away keep keep doing it we're watching
this closely thanks so much for coming
in good to see you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else